aquí
[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con entradas 24
mi nombre de liliana valencia hoy
hablaremos de la difícil situación por
la que atraviesan varios países de
latinoamérica debido a la pandemia de
ccoo y 19 por este tema hablamos con el
doctor oscar franco epidemiólogo
director del instituto de medicina
social y preventiva de la universidad de
berna académico de harvard y de la
universidad erasmo de rotterdam y asesor
científico también de france 24
bienvenidos nuevamente quiero
preguntarle colombia viene de varios
días con elevadas cifras de muertes por
ccoo y 19 el ministro de salud del país
hizo hincapié a los más de 40 días de
movilizaciones sociales cree usted que
ahí está el origen de esta escalada del
virus o se pierden de vista otros
elementos
creo que es una manera de simplificar un
bastante complejo fenómeno un fenómeno
que realmente está determinado por no
solamente el comportamiento de la
población sino también del
comportamiento del virus las medidas que
se toman y los programas de vacunación
que no van a la velocidad que se
necesita si estamos viendo aumento de
muertes y aumentos de casos ahora es
algo que estamos viendo desde marzo
colombia no es algo que empezó ahora de
hecho las aglomeraciones cuando empiezan
las únicas camas de cuidados intensivos
ya estaban casi a la mayor capacidad en
muchas de las ciudades de colombia
también es una situación que se está
viendo en toda latinoamérica
entonces nos invita a pensar que decir
que esto se debe a las aglomeraciones
cuando el virus no distingue cuando la
gente se reúne si es por política por
partidos de fútbol o por fiesta yo creo
que es una forma de simplificar una
situación un fenómeno que es bastante
complejo
hablemos ahora de uruguay durante el
primer año de la pandemia fue un país
casi ejemplar por el bajo nivel de
incidencia del virus pero la situación
es muy diferente que cree usted que
sucedió ya que se le atribuye esa
situación
si ahora mismo vemos a uruguay uruguay
como segundo país en el mundo después de
la república de sitges como con mayor
aumento de caso es la última semana y
como segundo país en el mundo después de
paraguay con mayor aumento de muertes de
hecho tenemos nueve entre los diez
primeros países que están en
latinoamérica en el mayor aumento de
muertes en la última semana uruguay tomó
medidas restrictivas fuertes en marzo de
2020 pudo controlarla la pandemia al
principio relajó las medidas hacia
mediados del 2020 y esas medidas se
mantienen así relajados desde entonces y
los casos empiezan a aumentar en
noviembre y ahora estamos viendo pues un
gran aumento en el número de casos y
muertes en uruguay esto se debe a la red
relajación de las medidas y también es
posible que lo que estamos viendo sea la
variante de uno que se reportó por
primera vez en brasil que causó estragos
en la población brasilera y que ha ido
pasando a afectar la región porque no
solamente uruguay sino también paraguay
y argentina están viéndose afectados
y hablemos ahora de chile la campaña de
vacunación en este país ha sido
considerada ejemplar a nivel mundial no
obstante el país no ha podido frenar los
contagios y las muertes e incluso el
gobierno implementó aislamientos
estrictos este año cómo explicar esta
situación
si ya hace poco veíamos como santiago de
chile- entrado nuevamente en cuarentena
chile ha sido un país modelo en los
programas de vacunación al igual que
uruguay del que ahora vamos a hacer poco
pero lo que estamos viendo es que las
medidas se tienen que mantener las
medidas de restricción las medidas de
distanciamiento de higiene se tienen que
mantener a pesar de que la vacunación
vaya bien la vacunación solo no puede
restringir al virus entonces es
necesario mantener las medidas y que la
población no se relaje después de
vacunarse
hay que continuar utilizando el
tapabocas manteniendo el distanciamiento
lavándose las manos y manteniendo la
higiene respiratoria bueno y por último
cuando los que características
particulares de la región de américa
latina además de la crisis económica en
muchos países pueden explicar la
situación actual en cuanto al kobe 19
si tenemos una región que se caracteriza
por la informalidad en el empleo que se
caracteriza por un medio sin gracia por
una cultura en la que nos abrazamos más
es nos queda más difícil mantener el
distanciamiento físico y adicionalmente
hemos visto años de pobre inversión en
términos de prevención y de sistemas de
salud entonces tenemos niveles altos de
obesidad del sedentarismo y de factores
de riesgo que contribuyen a tener mayor
complicación y mayor niveles de
mortalidad en términos de kobe 19
también hemos visto que es una región
que ha actuado sin mucha homogeneidad en
el manejo de la pandemia entonces se
necesita más coordinación en ese sentido
en toda la región pues agradecemos al
doctor oscar franco epidemiólogo y el
científico de france24 por estar con
nosotros y también usted gracias por
continuar con nuestra programación nos
vemos más adelante aquí hembras 24
[Música]